It's December 23rd. It's 2 days before
Christmas and my wife has abandoned me.
I'm trapped in mall traffic, sitting
behind the wheel. And in the backseat of
my car are truly two of the most
despicable and annoying human beings I
have ever met in my life. My children.
Clara is six and Charlie is three. And
there are people in the world who will
tell you these kids are brilliant beams
of light. But that is [__] because
they are just like my wife. They are
spending their entire lives trying to
slow me down and prevent me from doing
the things that I want to do. These are
children who literally stop and smell
the roses. My wife takes them to flower
shows because they ask to go to flower
shows. They stop me in parking lots and
say, "Look, Dad." And point to the
clouds and say, "That cloud looks like a
teapot. Take a picture." And I think I
just want to get in the store. And they
talk to everyone. They've talked to
random strangers all the time. They are
dangerously friendly children. And my
wife my my wife loves babies and she's
given this to my daughter. So everywhere
we go, my daughter stops mothers with
infants and she has conversations with
them like what's the name of your baby
and how old is the baby and breast or
bottle feeding? She's 6 years old and
she's just talking to everyone
and I'm sick of it. And on this day, it
is the worst day to slow me down because
it's December 23rd. I have to buy
Christmas presents because I haven't
bought a single present. And I am beyond
the Amazon Prime click and save your ass
date. So, I actually have to go into a
physical store and look at [__] on
shelves to determine which [__] belongs
to which person and what will look good
in wrapping paper. And I'm angry. This
day is going bad for me. And my wife had
the nerve on this day to get a haircut.
And when she goes to get a haircut, it
is a threehour ordeal. She is a woman
with short black hair. All she gets is a
trim, the trimmiest of trims. A trim I
don't even notice most of the time, but
it takes 3 hours because she begins the
process with someone who says, "What are
your goals for today?" That is [__] that
I cannot abide by. [laughter]
And so we're going to the mall, but we
can't go to the mall cuz my kids are
hungry and we have to be outside because
like my wife, no one wants to ever be in
the house but me, I make enormous
mortgage payments for a home nobody
wants to spend a moment in. So we go to
Panera. And when we go into Panera, I
know right away they've screwed up the
floor cuz they have the brown tiles
except an occasional red tile. And if
you have kids, you know that that means
your kids are just going to leap from
one red tile to the other and they're
going to knock people over and land
grilled cheese on the ground. So I say,
"Go to the dining room and find a
booth." And I know they're going to kill
each other while fighting over it, but I
don't care because they're not with me
right now. So I go to the cashier and
she's new. I can tell cuz she's nervous.
And so now I'm nervous. And I start
giving her the order and I say, "Listen,
my daughter is allergic to peanuts. Can
you please note it on the order?" And
she looks and she says, "Well, you
didn't order anything with peanuts." And
I'm like, "Ah." I say, "I know, but
could you just note it because she's
allergic and it's a good idea." And she
says, "Well, you really didn't order
anything with peanuts." And what I want
to say to her is, "Listen, lady, there's
a substance in this world that's
basically in every food, as far as I can
tell, that will kill my daughter if she
eats it. So, could you please just
[__] put peanuts on the order?" But I
don't do that because I'm a better
person than that. So, I charge past her.
I go past the counter and into the
employee area. I take two steps into the
kitchen and I go, "Listen, I'm you're
going to make a grilled cheese and when
you do," and then the manager's right in
front of me and she says, "Sir," and I
say, "No, you don't understand. Your
cashier will not put peanuts on the
order and my daughter's allergic and
she's not going to die today." And the
manager, to her everlasting credit,
softens. And she says, "Sir, I
understand and I will take care of it,
but you need to get out of my kitchen
right now." And she's right. I'm crazy.
And these kids have made me crazy. My
wife has made me crazy. I get out of the
kitchen. She finishes my order. I go to
the dining room to find my kids. And I
cannot believe what I see. They have
chosen a booth in the back. Clara is on
one side. Charlie is on the other side.
And in between there is a woman who I do
not recognize and an infant. They are
sitting with strangers.
[laughter]
And I'm thinking, how am I going to
solve this problem? But Clara knows what
I'm going to do because she says, "It's
okay, Dad." She said we can sit with
them and have lunch. This is Hannah. And
she points to the infant. [laughter]
And so I look at the woman and she looks
at me. She gives me that sign that I
know this is ridiculous, but let's do
this. And so I sit down with a stranger
at Panera.
And Clara introduces me to them and we
make some chitchat. And then she asks
the woman, she says, "Where's Hannah's
daddy today?" And the woman says, "Oh,
Hannah doesn't have a daddy." and my
wife and and Claraara says, "Oh, is it
are you a mommy mommy family?" And she
says, "No, it's just Hannah and me." And
that's the moment when I look at this
woman for the first time and I really
see her and I see the bags under her
eyes and the slumping shoulders and I
see the the stuff that she has
everywhere. She's got the stroller and
the car seat and the diapers and all the
plastic paraphernalia that we need to
keep kids alive today. The pacifiers and
the bottles. All stuff that I haven't
seen in a little while because my kids
are older. It's the first time I really
see this woman who's taking care of this
baby and all of this stuff by herself.
And I'm so angry at Claraara because she
has shown me the thing that I need to
see in this moment that I'm wandering
this world complaining because my wife
left me with my kids for three hours.
three stupid hours that I am complaining
about. I remember when Clara was born, I
thought we needed seven adults to keep
her alive. [laughter] And this woman is
doing it on her own. And she's smiling
and she is chatting with my daughter in
a way I have not chatted with her all
day. And I sit there with these two
brilliant beams of light knowing I am
never going to be as beautiful and as
wonderful as they are. Thank you.
[applause]
>> [cheering]